obviously you were the first one
eliminated this season I mean I know it
was a while ago but how did you feel in
that moment oh I was so sad I was really
devastated
um but I was you know really happy that
I got even had a chance to play the game
and I got to meet some incredible people
uh but my initial thoughts leaving the
game was like man like I was just
wanting to go back to the beach and
landed at the stars with all of my
tribees and so I was genuinely sad to be
saying goodbye did you feel differently
after watching it back
no not at all I don't have any ill will
toward anyone
um it it takes a lot to to make me stop
loving you like you have to be like a
really evil person uh but I think I went
into the game knowing it was a game I
came out of the game knowing it was a
game and so I think that everyone did
what they thought was in the interests
of them to get further and so that's
able to sit well with me
so you and the other ladies had talked
about working together were you
surprised that uh they chose to vote you
out
um no I didn't really know
um pre-tribal but I started to have a
gut feeling as we got closer to tribal
and then definitely while we were in
tribal there was a shift that happened
where in my gut I began to know it was
me so it wasn't really a a surprise when
Jeff said I'm gonna go grab the vote I
already was thinking about what I was
gonna say in my my final remarks uh
because I had felt that shift in tribal
uh but I definitely went into Tribal
Council hoping that the ladies would
stick it out with me
um and before tribal I truly thought
that that that Janine Ellie and Sammy
would stick together with the four
were you surprised by their reasoning to
vote you out
um yes
um because it wasn't something that I I
didn't know that that is how they
perceived me
um to be I didn't know that they viewed
me as the weakest or that was their
perception of me
um but although I was surprised it
didn't make me feel any kind of way
because I think that that was their
truth and their perception and they were
speaking to it but it's not what I know
to be true about myself and so it was
kind of just like water off the duck's
back
uh gabler had an immunity idol but he
didn't use it but like everybody was
sort of talking about like oh we can't
vote for him out because he has it I
mean do you kind of wish that people
have maybe taken that shot in the truth
that he didn't use it which obviously he
didn't no because I there's no way of
knowing no it's like a split second
anything could have happened anyone
could have said anything and he could
have chosen to play it and so I think
that I made the the best choice for my
game I wasn't gonna flip on my Women's
Alliance because it was something that I
really wanted to do not only did I think
it was the smartest choice for the women
but I'm like a woman's Alliance
something that the world needs to see we
have this really awesome connection with
samian so that made the four so the
smartest choice for us in that moment
would have been to get rid of Owen
because gabler was just too much of a
wild card if in one second he said I'm
gonna play my idol then all the votes
that we would have cast which would have
had been four or four or uh five if
Gaylord would have voted for us would
have been invalid and then whoever
gabler would have chosen to vote for
would have been the person going home
and so I think that that just would have
been too much of a gamble for us and it
wasn't a risk that I was willing to take
especially not for the first Tribal
Council
absolutely
um what did you enjoy most about
uh playing Survivor
the people the scenery the challenges I
really enjoyed pushing myself to the to
the Limit and seeing what I could handle
learning what I could do learning what I
was capable of what I was afraid to do
but what I what I still ended up doing
um all the challenges uh were really fun
and then just getting to know all these
incredible humans from around the world
that in any other area of my life I
would have probably have never met so
just learning uh people's stories
getting to know them and making those
bonds and those authentic genuine
connections that are probably going to
last a lifetime is definitely something
I'm taking with me outside of the game
that I enjoyed
um was there anything that sort of like
took you like by surprise or anything
that sort of shocked you about playing
Survivor no because I've been watching
since I was a kid so I already knew what
it was hidden for I'm like I'm about to
be starving it's getting ready to be hot
I'm gonna be tired it's gonna be a
Struggle Bus the one thing that I wasn't
a surprise what I was hoping for like in
my head I knew it wasn't true but I
still was like maybe hopefully we'll see
there might be a porta potty off camera
there wasn't one and so definitely going
to the bathroom in the trees in the
ocean was a struggle and something that
I had mentally prepared for uh but I was
just kind of hoping that you know and
this new era Survivor 26 days and a
porta potty but uh didn't give us that
maybe next season
um would you ever play Survivor again
oh absolutely in a heartbeat if Jeff
called me yesterday and if Jeff called
me tomorrow and said we want you back I
would have been on a plane yesterday
like it's like okay great going back in
time so I can already fly there uh and
I'm I'm just trying to manifest it right
now I'm like will I ever play again I'm
like no I'm gonna play again we're gonna
have a conversation Jeff let's talk
about it let's figure out uh this first
boot season Second Chances Redemption
whatever one you want to bring back I'm
hoping for for another shot
is there something you wish you had done
differently looking back
um I think not done differently but
something I do wonder and I I mentioned
this earlier with um saying maybe I
should have played like it was my second
chance like maybe I should have played
my shot in the dark you know and maybe
it would have been really cool to be the
first person ever in Survivor history to
be saved by the shot in the dark so
sometimes I'm like I feel like if I
would play again chances in taking risks
like that might pay off it might not but
that or just blow it up Tribal Council
and saying hey ladies we already know
we're getting rid of oh and let's just
put it out in the open and see where
things go from there and so taking big
risky moves like that
um is something I think that I uh look
back and I wonder necessarily don't
regret not doing them I like the way I
played my game but I wonder how things
could have turned out or panned out had
I done that instead
uh lastly uh at this point uh in the
season who are you rooting for
all of baka I can't really choose
between any of them I love all of my
tribe mates I'm proud of all of them
um I have done you in connections with
all of them so for any of them to go far
I think that that would be really
beautiful to see
well thank you so much for taking me my
Philly peeps too I got my Philly peeps
over there on Coco laughs
love it uh thank you again for taking
the time really appreciate it and I hope
you have a good rest of your day thank
you too